[Music]
we're driving out to Long Island today
because we found out there's a man out
there who legally changed his name to
Santa Claus so yeah we're gonna go
interview Santa it turns out this Santa
is not so traditional
I Drive a black Dodge pickup truck with
vanity plates oh yes I have vanity
plates this is Santa's sleigh before he
was Santa
he was Frank was born in Brooklyn but we
lived here on Long Island I have been
married 23 years now so how do you tell
your wife that you're changing your name
to Santa Claus she said as long as I
don't have to change my name
go right ahead Santa has been Santa for
almost two decades and he's good at it
I'm probably on and this is not an
exaggeration
thousands of refrigerators you've got
the laughs oh you know that's that's my
Santa laughs the suit I designed my suit
but here are some other things about
Santa that might surprise you I have
three tattoos on me of me
I'm very into zombies I love barbecue I
have a smoker they can fit 150 pounds of
meat in he's got this tiki hut and
above-ground saltwater pool in his
backyard yes I'm that extreme when it
comes to my idea of relaxation so
there's a little Frank left in there but
no question he's fully committed to
being Santa I want to look like the poem
says I'm the most loved person on
[Music]
everybody knows jolly old Saint Nick
he's the bearer of good tidings and
cheer well in Austria he's not alone and
we don't mean Rudolph
[Music]
these are Krampus a sort of monster that
travels with Saint Nick they scare away
bad spirits and look for naughty kids to
punish making Christmas a whole lot
scarier people in Europe have been
welcoming the Christmas season by
dressing his Krampus for hundreds of
years
I am Ralph Hetzel and I am the oldest
Krampus here in town out Market and the
5th of December we came to the child in
their homes and the good one gets some
sweets from the nicolò and the pepped
ones get hit with the whip from the
Krampus then we go from house to house
for five six hours and after we recently
to all the children in out mark there's
a little run with all Krampus together
[Music]
the story of Saint Nick and Krampus goes
back to 375 ad and the costumes and
traditions haven't changed much since
the dress from the Krampus is made of
wool from the Sheep the masks are made
of wood and so when you're walking
around to all the children to their
houses for some hours you really will
get sweat it's a likely work out it's
funny to go into the houses for me
people their reaction is different some
childs are not scared come to you and
grab to affirm in other ones screaming
and running away the Krampus is a good
reason to change their mind from the
children try to be good for the next
year I am dressed as Krampus this year
the 15-time very lucky to go every year
I'm very proud to be a part of this
whole tradition
[Music]
these Santa's are all really kids at
heart they like the fun and laughter
that comes with it and making people
happy that's why we're here you ask them
why they're staying up most of them will
tell you because they enjoyed being a
child so they're going back to that
they're reliving your childhood it's a
wonderful thing
welcome everyone to the Charles W Howard
80th anniversary Santa Claus school
[Applause]
[Music]
you better watch out you better not cry
I'm telling you why Santa Claus my name
is Tom Villette I'm the Dean of the
Charles W Howard Santa Claus School in
Midland Michigan this is the Harvard
Isana school it's the oldest running
Santa Claus School in the world started
by Charlie Howard in 1937 at Santa Claus
school we learned everything from beard
keeping to personal hygiene time making
to what it feels like to ride on the
Polar Express flying the sleigh Santa
has to be healthy he's a healthy
outdoorsman if you're not healthy you're
gonna drift off you're not gonna pay
attention it's very important to have
all the skills you can to be a great
Santa because the child is gonna
remember this visit for the rest of your
life Merry Christmas
[Music]
when Charlie had the school he had three
or four students some good years maybe
15 students this year we have 214 it
just grows
we have Santa's of course from almost
every state in the United States we have
around 20 Santa's from Canada we have
three Santa's from Denmark
one from Norway and one from Germany
there's a real sense of camaraderie in
this school it's like this large Santa
family coming together they share
stories they learn from each other we
want to be Santa's to make people happy
when we get together we're making each
other happy
I love it once they leave this school I
hope that each and every Santa and mrs.
Claus goes out and spreads the spirit of
Christmas spreads the love and joy that
we have here at this school and passes
it on to all the little children and all
the families when you give joy you get
it back to fold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we got you something Oh what is it
come on open it up oh okay thanks
no honestly this little guy is a big
deal in Catalonia to explain why we got
a head to toe fella de menthe agrees a
town in the Catalonia region of Spain
and to Barcelona a little later but
anyways back to Tahoe le de menthe agree
home to this man known in a way this one
posh area las llaves
hey go what gah gah net colony una
persona que está siendo shows necesidad
Agora in English at - [ __ ] Peron Carinae
is from a p.m. with traditional Muay and
we catalana in Catalonia when you put up
your nativity scene you have Mary Joseph
of course baby Jesus some kings and this
guy yep
the cagin air hockey hace lo de hecho
para encontrar una súplica see on yo
tyranny feliz navidad en el campo portal
de fertility yvonne of la la tierra oh
no dinero Karenina
comport Aventura Milosh worthy so in
someone's home there he is in this
museum there he is
well there's even one in this street
nativity scene okay this is definitely
not a joke can we now talk about your
latest business idea Astaire's mark my
hermano
yes tom Barcelona up in the end oh yeah
tour scariness desde que le [ __ ]
mascara Anastos persona has no Kampala
Tico's foot ballistas gente la cultura
la demanda kahani no fue su viendo el
principio un poco de incredulous ad no
de que esto no despues cuando el en un
poquito la tradición pues es el O'Meara
no yatra manera a Mucha gente que VA a
comprar my collection is Amira's que
tengo un sitio la parada llevaba y que
cuando voy me quieres entir accompanied
oh no he is Lepore en el agua see there
you go a gift for all year round
[Music]
I'm Jan Ken guard CEO of king-size Bo's
incorporated and welcome to my beau
Kingdom
[Music]
we're in the joy business we make
special occasions special I have to say
that our most popular bow is our
signature monarch both the red and
silver one
the Lexus commercials that we've had the
privilege of doing for the last eight
years has really drawn attention to the
multi loop bows we're the only ones in
the United States who actually make
those bows we make them out of a variety
of fabrics and textures and those are
the ones that people are most interested
in there's a whole bow language that
most people don't speak but there are
definitely differences of opinions about
how many loops how long the tails should
be and whether there's a V cut or an
angled cut we are pleased to be in every
showroom from Ferrari to the many to the
Ford to BMW now we've found that
customers really expect to keep the bow
when they buy the car they want to drive
away with the bow you'd be surprised
where people put bows
it's not just on top of a car any place
that you want to say look at me look at
me it can be on a bicycle or a surfboard
or skis on a gate on the top of your
house at a pinnacle
[Music]
we have six weeks to harvest a million
Christmas
and that means you gotta move fast
[Music]
as soon as harvest starts it's time to
call in the Calvary
[Music]
the state organ is the largest supplier
of Christmas trees in the country here
in Oregon Christmas trees outnumber
people twelve to one holiday tree farms
is one of the largest Christmas tree
farms in the world we have about 8,000
acres of actively growing trees the only
thing we grow is Christmas trees we sell
a million Christmas trees a year but you
gotta remember we harvest them in a very
short period of time we can cut and
process a Christmas tree and have it
loaded on a truck in less than 24 hours
the steps in harvesting and Christmas
trees start with cutting each treat
individually with a chainsaw sling those
will pile the trees and rig them for
extraction next we bring a helicopter
and fly them into waiting trucks each
tree is shaken bailed loaded and then
it's on its way to market
[Music]
although they started using helicopters
in the early 1980s
throw a lot faster than you doing it by
hand
the helicopter can harvest met a
thousand trees an hour we normally run
between five or six helicopters every
day sunup to sundown
[Music]
we've been taking care of these trees
ever since they were very tiny seedlings
an average noble fir is about eight
years old when harvested and six to
seven feet tall harvest is my favorite
time of the year
that's when we get to see the payoff
four six seven eight years worth of work
for every tree that we harvest we plant
another tree in its place so when we
harvest a million trees we plant over a
million trees the next spring it never
stops
so what do I think of fake trees is a
Christmas tree farmer door number one
competition obviously we're all tree
farmers I was saying about fig trees
nine years in the house and nine million
years in landfill they cannot be
recycled it's Christmas keep it
you